>>Presenter: So good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to the authors at Google series.
My name is Scott Sheffer and itís my pleasure
to introduce Professor Edith Sheffer to all
of you.
Yes weíre married.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: So thatís the connection, thatís
how we got her to come to Google.
Edithís an assistant Professor of history
at Stanford University.
She graduated summa cum laude from Harvard
University with a BA in history and literature
and then attended Berkeley for her PhD studying
under Jerry Feldman.
She was a Mellon Fellow in the history department
at Stanford before joining the faculty as
an assistant Professor in September of 2010.
Sheís also the winner of several teaching
awards at Berkeley and Stanford and published
an article in the Chronicle called ìHigher
Educationî in 2009 on her revolutionary teaching
methods.
These methods are now actually being adopted
in high schools, community colleges and universities
around the world.
Her recently completed book Burned Bridge:
How East and West Germans Made the Iron Curtain
challenges the conventional history of the
iron curtain suggesting how the physical barrier
that was imposed between East and West Germany
was not just imposed by cold war super powers
but was an outgrowth of anxious activities
and anxious people on the ground.
The book examines the growth and genesis of
the border through the lens of two adjacent
cities; Neustadt bei Coburg and Sonneberg
that were the largest separated population
outside of Berlin.
It was, in fact, the American military that
erected the first border barriers between
the two East, West Germanys.
Iíll leave other juicy anecdotes to Edith
but be prepared to be surprised about what
happened at the beginnings of the iron curtain.
Without further ado Iíll turn it over to
Edith and weíll have some Q&A afterward.
[Applause]
>>Edith Sheffer: Thank you, Scott.
Thank you all so much for coming here today.
I really look forward to telling you about
my research and, as Scott said, what I find
to be surprising and exciting stories.
Today, as Scott indicated, Iíll be taking
a rather unconventional look at the creation
of the wall between East and West Germany
and this research is really the first social
history of the iron curtain.
We have a lot of military and diplomatic histories
of how this barrier was built, but I wonít
be looking at the role of high politics, rather,
Iíll be looking at the role of the residents
who lived on either side of this fence.
And, so, Iíll be spotlighting today how one
cohesive community in the absence of linguistic,
religious or cultural differences began to
see people, right on the opposite side of
this fence, as other.
Creating difference where there was no difference.
So although Germany had been united, it was
one country and under Hitler it was supposed
to be a thousand year Reich, right at the
end of World War Two the allies imposed a
temporary demarcation line which then gradually
became the creation of difference where there
was no difference.
The institutionalization of violence among
neighbors and popular participation in a system
that was deeply unpopular.
And what I think is so fascinating about this
story is how so quickly people normalized
a monstrosity in their midst.
So my central claim in a nutshell is that
the lethal barrier between East and West Germany
was not simply imposed by Communism, as we
tend to think, but that it emerged haphazardly
from both East and West and that ordinary
people played a significant role in its creation.
So, let me just give you an overview of the
talk today.
First Iíll begin with the broader context
of this project, giving an outline of the
book as a whole which I see was given out
freely and then Iíll delve into two examples
from my research at very different points
in time, one from the late 1940s when the
border was still an invisible line and one
from the 1980s when the border was at its
absolute height.
And Iíll conclude with the implications of
this work, not only for an understanding of
Germany and the Cold War but, also, for understanding
borders, partitions and identities today.
And, above all, throughout this talk Iíll
be emphasizing the importance of social fabric,
describing how the strength of Germanyís
wall and many of the institutions we take
for granted today, come as much from concrete
as it does from the society that supports
their creation.
So as fortified borders proliferate around
the world today such as those between the
U.S. and Mexico or the security fence in Israel,
Germanyís story, I think, warns us that walls
can permeate the culture with enduring and
even deadly consequences.
Micro steps can have far reaching results.
[Pause]
>>Edith Sheffer: So, compared to international
relations today, the Cold War, in retrospect,
can appear to be a simpler, steadier time.
And nothing represents this so clearly as
the Berlin Wall which remains the stark symbol
of East, West conflict, conflict.
And, in popular imagination as well as in
scholarship, the iron curtain appears to be
monolithic.
It was imposed unilaterally by Communism,
imprisoning East Germans from escaping to
freedom in the West; weíve all heard this
story.
And for the West during the Cold War, the
Berlin Wall underpinned a moral consensus
against Communism.
From JFK, you see him in the lower left there,
his Ich bin ein Berliner speech as well as
Ronald Reaganís, ìMr. Gorbachev tear down
this wall!î These are iconic moments in the
Cold War.
But today Iíd like to turn this on its head
and present a very different, story revealing
the human underpinnings of the supposedly
iron barrier.
This is the, uh, the celebrations of in 19,
in 2009 of its fall, I think only underscores
have the symbolic significance of the Berlin
Wall has transcended the Cold War.
So yes, the Berlin Wall did go up overnight
in 1961.
But what happened in Berlin, Iíll be arguing,
is just one part of a much longer story of
the entire iron curtain.
The Berlin Wall was only the final and most
famous portion of the iron curtain to be built.
The Berlin Wall had a very complicated genealogy.
Before it appeared another longer barrier
had been growing between the Germanys for
16 years.
So after World War Two the allies divided
Germany into four occupation zones.
You see the Soviet Zone, the US Zone, the
British Zone and the French Zone and each
of these zones had demarcation lines between
them and the laws were the same on each of
these borders.
Very quickly, this border between the Western
zones and the Soviet zones became incredibly
problematic.
Soviet soldiers were prone to theft and rape
over the border and very soon economic imbalances
between the two sides led to a lot of smuggling
and migration.
So this developed into a fourteen hundred
kilometer border which if you cut the US in
half itís roughly the distance from Chicago
to New Orleans.
So, as you can see, much longer than what
happened in Berlin which remained occupied
by the four powers until 1961 and Berlin remained
open until then.
So, I am not sure why this longer border has
claimed so much less attention to the, than
the Berlin Wall.
Iíd be curious to hear your thoughts as to
why.
But there are very few books written about
this other longer barrier.
The books that we have really portray this
border as a military installation imposed
by Communism with the populace having very
little to do with its construction.
This is a military impassable barrier.
Now there are several scholarly works under
way in Germany and in the US and Iíll be
curious to see how this image of the border
changes over time.
But when I began my research it was certainly
eye opening to see just how dynamic this border
was.
The archives revealed how civilians and local
officials participated in its construction
and how this barrier was really woven into
the fabric of local communities.
So here, on the left, you see a brigade of
civilians in 1952 clearing logs to build border
fortifications.
Now, this is a tricky photo to read.
How can we, in a coercive brutal regime like
East Germany, how can we tell what these people
are actually thinking, what their motivations,
to what extent are they being coerced and
who are we to evaluate them?
So, in going to the archives and researching
this deeply, it does become clear that there
are several acts of resistance, that it was
possible to walk off a job like this with
and without repercussions.
Did people, were people aware to the extent
that this was possible?
How do we know?
It is also clear from the archives that there
were widespread complicity and compliance.
East German civilians wound up initiating
one in five of all escape arrests as denunciations
or as voluntary border helpers.
So my question became, how did people accept
and even perpetuate this strange dividing
line that suddenly appeared in their midst?
So my research has yielded three interrelated
answers to this question which Iíll be going
into in more depth but Iíll be showing how
the early form of the border was extremely
open ended.
Neither East nor West had a coherent plan
for this thing let alone a strategy.
And their policies continued to develop ad
hoc in response to each otherís moves and
counter moves.
So the border emerged bit by bit more in response
to conditions on the ground.
Second, I argue that Germanyís division ran
deeper than as realized, penetrating mentalities.
Germanyís, Germans rapidly formed oppositional
identities within a few years as Easterners
and Westerners attributing entirely different
values in characteristics to people on each
side.
So although the actual shape of the border
was in extreme flux people perceived it to
be a fete accompli and it, sort of, preemptively
anticipating the borders a fete accompli,
it made it happen.
So Iíll be going through some instances of
how this happened as we go on.
So poignantly, frontier populations adjusted
to something that was not static and in so
doing, made it a reality that most did not
want.
So, as Scott had mentioned, my research centers
upon these two towns and I picked them because
theyíre almost identical.
Itís a perfect political science experiment.
These towns are the same size, about 25,000
people each and socioeconomically incredibly
similar.
The American army occupied Neustadt at the
end of World War Two and the Soviet army occupied
Sonneberg.
And very quickly, the two military governments
imposed very different systems of laws on
each side.
So because my argument is, oh and I canít
leave out Burned Bridge was the name of the
check point that was established between the
two towns.
It was named after the road crossing between
them, conveniently for me itís also a great
metaphor for what I believe happened there.
So because my argument is about all the little
ways that the iron curtain became effect,
my approach was basically to canvas all available
sources.
I went to 14 different archives in both East
and West looking at city, county, state and
national records including secret police files
and American military records.
I went through local newspaper, journals,
periodicals, uh, school work assignment, anything
I could get my hands on to kind of portray
this multiplicity of perspectives.
I lived in these places.
I conducted interviews with over 50 people
ranging from border officials to border victims
and I also conducted a mailed survey to 500
people.
And because of this multilayered approach,
for any given event I have different perspectives
that often present very conflicting narratives.
And itís precisely these gaps in these different
perspectives that I think speaks volumes and
really conveys the uncertainty and confusion
that I believe drove much of the borders development.
So, before going into my examples, Iíd like
to give you a quick overview of the development
of the iron curtain.
The thickness of this line denotes the thickness
of the barrier at any point in time.
And Iíve periodized it into three phases.
In the late 1940s, right after the military
governments are established, Burned Bridge
was a busy check point.
there was a customs house right here.
The demarcation was unfenced, it was invisible,
poorly guarded and was basically a chaotic
crime zone.
And, as Scott had said, it was basically the
American military who built the first barriers
here to contain this crime zone.
Then in the 1950s and 52í, East Germany first
decided to build the first extensive fence
network.
Not so much to keep people in, escape was
not the primary concern in 1952.
The motive here was to stabilize what had
been such a chaotic region.
So residents could still cross very easily,
though, people on both sides progressively
internalized this and this period is what
I call, a period of a living wall which was
what, actually, the West German minister for
all German questions wanted it to be.
The population was supposed to constitute
a living wall.
Then in the 1960s, by the time East Germany
built the Berlin Wall in 1961, a lethal border
was already in place.
And you can see here, that house had been
bulldozed and you see multiple layers of barbed
wire at Burned Bridge.
And the modern border continued to grow, you
get land mines, dog run, signal fences and
trip wires, this is a formidable barrier now.
So much so that when the iron curtain finally
fell in 1989, people were euphoric and it
was a bewildering experience.
And now Burned Bridge is a bustling commercial
center with Ronald presiding over two competing
malls on each side.
So since the book talks about the aggregate
effects of small decisions and small adjustments,
it is difficult to convey in a talk like this
the sheer breadth of everyday actions and
mentalities that I believe gave rise to the
border.
It is also difficult to convey exactly what
I mean by people when I say people made the
iron curtain.
I do not mean to suggest that local people
uniformly wanted this border to exist, far
from it.
Rather, I mean a range of people acting at
different times for a range of different reasons,
added up together to a structure that no one
intended.
So to give you an example of the kinds of
evidence Iím looking at and to differentiate
these people so much, somewhat, letís return
to the time of the American and Soviet military
occupations.
The border, as Iíd said, was a sight of endemic
theft, abduction, rape and shootings and it
was technically illegal to cross but locals
still went back and forth all the time, especially
Eastern smugglers, undocumented workers and
migrants.
So here is an East German woman caught by
a Western border guard.
Sheís smuggling toy ornaments which were
masses produced in the area Iím studying.
[Laughter]
>>Edith Sheffer: And then here you have workers
crossing illegally.
And hundreds and hundreds of people were crossing
every day in the late 1940s.
So increasingly, West Germans began resenting
these Eastern crossers who were poorer, they
were dressed worse and they were taking their
jobs.
This sounds familiar.
[Laughter]
>>Edith Sheffer: And, in fact, the dynamic
of this early border was not dissimilar to
the US, Mexican border today.
Where there is local impetus to increase border
escalations.
So, Western border residents undertook a wide
range of actions against these Eastern border
goers.
And, today, I just wanna give you an example
of what happened in judicial prosecutions.
So three years after the demarcation line
first appears the Western mayor of Neustadt
calls for quote, I know this is difficult
to read, ìThe immediate strengthening of
the Border Police and the creation of an effective
system of summary courts."
And then he called a meeting with Bavarian
official, American officials to define border
crime.
What is a border crime?
So the Neustadt border court tried over a
thousand defendants over the next three years.
And the local archives had actually slated
these border trials for destruction.
Saying that they had little historical value
because there were so many of them and they
were meaningless.
And I really argued for this not to happen
because I think that they reveal a lot about
this dynamic in the early period.
So immediately after the mayorís initiative
Western law targeted Easterners.
Over 90 percent of the courts defendants were
Eastern border smugglers and undocumented
workers mostly from the neighboring town of
Sonneberg.
So their former neighbors are now getting
arrested for crossing and taking their jobs.
Even more interesting, I think, is that the
definition of border crime then shifts abruptly.
The economic situation began improving, anti
communism was growing and suddenly Western
leftists became the targets of prosecution.
Westerners were attending communist events
in the east, they were transporting propaganda
and these are now the people who become arrested.
So what does this mean?
When I present my work I often get the question,
ìWasnít this border inevitable?
Come on, you have the US army on one side,
the Soviet army on the other side, what is
it, really, that I expect local people to
have done?î And my response is, of course
no one would have denied the geopolitical
conditions created the conditions in which
the iron curtain arose, I donít mean to imply
that they donít.
But we already know a lot about high level
decision making and structural differences
between East and West.
So what Iím saying is that while states created
the condition for the border they did not
control its outcome.
And local responses like this are vital to
understanding how it actually developed into
what national bodies were responding to.
So, especially, in this early period, the
American and Soviet military governments had
no plans for this border.
They were busy catching Naziís
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: They were busy rebuilding
the economy, they were busy implementing new
systems of government, the border was not
a priority.
And, so, because of this vacuum of power this
allowed local government to take initiative
and shape what this border actually meant.
So here, because the US military was not doing
its job, this Western mayor took over.
So this is just one example of many suggesting
how such actions combined with others and
others and others, in aggregate could have
created this phenomenon.
So Iíd like to give another example from
the 1940s which I think demonstrates the kind
of interactivity that was driving the borders
growth.
So, this is a fun story.
In July 1949 there was a soccer game near
Burned Bridge, between the two towns, and
the game was supposedly on the border so the
midfield line was the border so the people
could attend the game without applying for
inter zonal passes, though the players whoíd
be running in between the zones needed passes
in order to play the game.
So the game was a major event.
25,000 people came and it was experienced
and remembered as a demonstration of local
unity.
But when you go to the archives, however,
you see a very different story.
First it turns out the game was not actually
over the border but no one knew where the
border lay,
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: So it was entirely within
the Soviet Zone because it was the Communist
party in the Soviet Zone that planned the
game.
It was not a local initiative.
And Communists in the Soviet Zone were planning
border events all along the demarcation line
in order to unsettle the West, to sort of
foment activity on the border.
So after the game, the Soviet commander of
Sonneberg announced that the demarcation line
would be open for the day.
So you have Easterners lining up on the demarcation
line, this invisible line, and I find this
picture incredible.
You have a crowd standing on an invisible
line not crossing.
And then all of a sudden people begin to cross
and because thereís so many of them they
quickly overrun West German and American forces.
So here theyíre rushing across and they soon
overwhelm border guards and they scream into
Neustadt, bartering, whatever it is they happened
to bring over.
So, while at the same time, only 400 Westerners
reportedly crossed to the East.
So you have this enormous display of enthusiasm
going from East to West but not West to East.
And, in fact, if you interview Westerners
about this event, theyíll say that although
it was great to see their friends and families
and neighbors again, the Eastern crowds were
much too much and they were happy when the
Sonnebergers went back home again.
So the Soviet Zone then organized three more
mass crossings that fall, numbering about
20,000 people each.
This was an incredibly huge event and this
made for good propaganda.
Here, again, you see East Germans lined up
along an invisible line with Americans confronting
them with machine guns.
And, so, this is a picture that was published
in a Soviet Zone newspaper to demonstrate,
you know, the fallacy of Western claims for
openness.
And at the same time Westerner newspapers
portrayed this differently.
The New York Times described the Easterners
as mobs of shabby people resembling a swarm
of locusts.
Westerners complained about these repeat invasions
demanding state compensation cause their stores
were selling out of wares and local politicians
begged the US military government to increase
border controls to stop these mass crossings
from happening.
So Western authorities responded to this local
pressure and there were ramifications of these
crossings along the entire border.
These crossings led to security escalations.
So today, however, these crossings are remembered
very differently as spontaneous expressions
of neighborly solidarity.
So in the survey I did, I threw in a question
about this and of 112 respondents that were
born before 1945, so theyíd have some living
memory of this, 81 percent remembered the
crossings as joint local initiatives.
Only 9 percent said they were organized by
the communist party and the Soviet Zone.
And, indeed, when I talk to locals about this
they look at me very skeptically because this
doesnít tally with their memory at all.
And in a television interview about this soccer
game, one man from the region just rejected
it out of hand saying, ìNo, I donít believe
you.î
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: So the memory of the border
is as important to understanding it today
as what actually happened.
But what I think is most significant about
these mass crossings, hereís another picture
of the invisible line, is that they were extremely
one sided and extremely short lived.
So just 4 years after the fall of the thousand
year Reich, thousands of Easterners were rushing
to Neustadt while only a few hundred Westerners
were going East.
And they also reveal how partition had become
an established reality.
The openings were exciting and disruptive
precisely because the border was an established
fact of everyday life.
So, although these crowds easily overwhelmed
US and Western border forces, the next day
border discipline returned to normal each
time.
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: So you have four mass crossings
and then four returns to normalcy which I
think makes the sensation of these mass crossings
all the more revealing.
What is keeping crowds from doing this everyday
when thereís no real threat of force?
So I believe these 1949 mass crossings expose
not the strength of the physical barrier,
there is no physical barrier, but its dependence
upon local compliance.
And you see local compliance just four years
after the end of the third Reich.
So Germanyís divide was not a fortification
as much as it was a living wall.
And itís the adjustment of these post war
populations that then enabled the border to
persist and expand.
[Clears throat]
>>Edith Sheffer: Now this argument is very
easy to make for the immediate post war period
when border policy and the two German states
were in extreme flux.
But I believe the border residence played
an important role in later events as well.
So, for example, in 1952 East Germany builds
the first fences and it deports in something
it names action vermin, over 8,000 border
residence who they deem unreliable for their
inland.
So you have these local deportation actions
where local people are these sort of paramilitary
police units that go up to peopleís houses,
load their furniture and the residence on
a truck and drive them to new homes for their
inland.
And what I think is interesting is with this
action vermin it came as a complete shock
and you see a wide range of responses.
Some local officials helped draft the deportation
lists.
No one in Berlin knew these peopleís names
so it was local officials that conducted this.
At the same time, some officials would tip
off friends who were on the list so they could
escape.
Some towns remained quiet when these trucks
pulled up, watching from the windows as their
neighbors were loaded on to these trucks.
Some towns took to the streets and built barricades
and went out with pitchforks quashed only
by Soviet tanks, Soviet tanks went into some
of these places.
One entire village named Libow escaped West
overnight, 63 people just moved across the
border at once.
So the outcome of action vermin in each community
depended largely upon the extent to which
locals caused trouble.
So if you go through the rates of deportation,
towns that remained relatively calm would
see deportation rates of 65 to 80 percent
where as towns that caused trouble could see
the ratio of removed victims as low as 0 to
10 percent.
So, to me, this variability of response and
variability of consequences reveals just how
large a factor the border population was in
understanding its escalation.
So, although, my point is that while the specific
border dynamic changes over time, this is
a very different event than, say, the mass
crossings I just described.
There was always a dynamic at work here and
itís important to understanding how the iron
curtain actually evolved.
So my book goes through each phase of the
Cold War but now Iíd like to skip ahead to
the height of the border where itís very
difficult to make this argument that the local
populations played a role in its creation.
And this is probably the more controversial
aspect of my work to make this argument for
a time period where the border was already
established.
So this is the same sight that we just saw
of the 1949 mass crossings, remember that
invisible line?
Now itís a mesh fence.
Behind it are booby traps, mines, self firing
devices; dog runs, a lethal installation.
So in thirty years life itself in Sonneberg
had dramatically changed.
East Germany had established a military zone
behind the fortifications so the people living
within 5 kilometers of the border, everyone
in this photograph lived in what was called
a prohibited zone.
This encompassed about 2 percent of East Germanyís
entire population, about 400,000 people.
So you can imagine the logistical undertaking
of 2 percent of the population living in a
prohibited zone.
And you could only enter the prohibited zone
with a special permit.
You faced a constant threat of deportation.
I estimate that about a thousand Sonnebergers
were deported over the years.
Within this zone was an even stricter 500
meter zone or protection strip.
Here you lived under tight curfews and a range
of daily prohibitions and you were part of
border enforcement, even your children were
trained in border enforcement.
You were supposed to report outsiders coming
in to the area and serve as volunteer border
helpers.
To compensate border residents for these hardships
East Germany paid residents 15 percent salary
bonuses.
So if you lived here you got a higher salary.
And this, incidentally, proved so popular
that some communities lobbied to be included
in the military zone in order to get these
bonuses.
The dynamic in the border zone was fascinating
and Iím happy to talk about it in discussion
but Iím gonna move onto the rest of my story,
but how this was established is fascinating
in and of itself.
So, because this border regime was so elaborate
it is hardly surprising that West Germans
seized upon East Germany's border as inhumane.
But itís important to recognize how the West
German media and government exaggerated the
horrors of the border.
Rhetoric of it as a concentration camp wall.
It helped strengthen West Germanyís western
alliances and was useful fodder for the Cold
War.
Newspapers were full of headlines about East
Germans trying to escape tyranny, getting
blown up, dying at the fortification and itís
true, of course this happened and these are
terrible tragic stories.
Yet the headlines were not always right.
This headline is wrong on several accounts.
I donít know if anyone in the audience speaks
German but this 16 year old boy, it describes,
was not escaping from the East he was escaping
to the East from an abusive childrenís home
in the West.
And this happened, Westerners did escape east.
And he didnít die, as the headline claims
but he wound up in Sonnebergís hospital and
actually praised his treatment there by East
German officials.
The government also exaggerated the strength
of the border.
This is a publicized diagram from 1965 that
overstates and condenses the fortifications.
The exaggeration continues today.
This is a video reconstruction on YouTube
that was produced by Deutsche Welle, you know,
the main, yeah, news network by Germany today
and it shows only a very unusually fortified
section of the border.
So itís not an exaggeration but itís a very
specialized place that had been on the iron
curtain.
Western representations really reinforced
the image of the iron curtain as an inevitable,
inescapable reality.
In turn, West Germany turned the border into
a tourist attraction.
The government subsidized trips to the border
land.
Border guards led border tours.
You could take bus rides, visit museums, buy
postcards and ponder the horrors of totalitarianism
at Neustadtís booming border cafÈ.
Thereís the iron curtain.
So here we are defending, um, yeah.
These are East German images of the border.
These are also ominous images but very different.
On a rare occasion the border was shown in
East Germany it appears not as a prison wall
but as action shots of handsome soldiers in
combat, right, theyíre defending against
fascism in the west.
But on both sides, basically, youíre presented
a formidable frontier.
I hope you can see this, this is, this border
really did work.
This is the drop in escapes from 1961when
the border was seriously fortified and how
the number drops to under 100 escapes a year
by the 1970s.
So imagine a line from Chicago to New, New
Orleans only 100 people getting across that
every year.
Thatís what these numbers suggest, incredibly
effective, right?
So, but if you look beyond the border forces
official reports you quickly get a different
picture than this number would suggest.
So letís take 1982 this is what Iíve highlighted.
There was 72 reported escapes, only 72.
But, again, if you dig into this a little
deeper here is a letter from a woman in a
Sonneberg community in 1982 and she mentions
to her relatives in Neustadt that her son
quote, ìCame over the border again to visit
us today.î
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: And although this kind of
evidence is anecdotal there are such fragments
in peopleís attics and conversations that
local people were crossing.
And what I think is even more interesting
is what border agencies knew about these local
crossings.
For example, hereís a document from East
Germanyís stasi or secret police and it describes
the antics of three young men who within 6
months in 1982, crossed the border 45 times.
[Laughter]
>>Edith Sheffer: They were stealing mines
from the border fortifications and selling
them to West German and American service men
on the other side.
So this document shows 45 crossings in 6 months,
contrast that with 72 reported escapes.
So the irony with this story with the crossing
boys is that East German border forces didnít
even know the boys were crossing until they
were arrested in West Germany for selling
the mines.
It was illegal in West Germany to vandalize
the fortifications.
So these cases raised the obvious question,
how much crossing was really happening over
the border?
And they also raise a question about reporting.
Government agencies knew about these local
crossings but their number did not make it
into official tallies nor were they publicized
in the press.
Why?
Well, East Germany certainly had no interest
in admitting that the border was more vulnerable
than it projected and West Germany had a policy
of not publicizing crossings.
It didnít want to endanger East German families
and it also didnít wanna lead East Germans
to believe that crossing was not a dangerous
possibility.
These locals knew what they were doing and
the outsiders did not.
But I do wonder if these numbers were publicized
in some fashion would it have changed peopleís
perception of the barrier and if people had
known the barrier was more porous would it
have changed its reality?
And what was the borderís reality, really?
How is it possible to cross this formidable
barrier?
And the short answer is local knowledge, that
the border was enmeshed in local life.
This is a scrapbook from a border soldier
in the 1960s and it, to me, really speaks
to how border residents were part of the border
regime.
This was a living, breathing system that was
peopled by people.
Here you see photos of his buddies chatting
with this local woman, Frieda, and hereís
his favorite pub in the area where he was
stationed.
So, the border residents were part of the
system and knew how it worked.
And the strength of the iron curtain really
depended upon these people.
As Iíd said, less than one fifth, or I hadnít
said this, less than one fifth of all escapes
were caught by border soldiers at the fortifications,
less than a fifth.
The rest were caught by local and transport
police further inland and up to a quarter
were turned in by local civilians, these volunteer
border helpers and denunciations.
So in the story I just told one of the young
men that had crossed the border 23 times in
6 months, his mother was a cook for the border
troops and his dad actually worked for the
Stasi, East Germanyís secret police.
So he knew the patrol routes and where the
fortifications were the weakest.
He grew up in this kind of border regime.
So what I think is so amazing is that the
very same people who were buttressing the
iron curtain, making it function, making it
possible, were in a position to subvert it
and they did subvert it even though they would
denounce you or me if we walked into the border
zone.
So here we have a bit of a paradox, we have
a strong border that was oddly porous to the
same people who were making it possible, who
had this inside knowledge but were keeping
it strong to outsiders.
So I donít wanna lead you astray, Iíve gotten
a lot of criticism for making this argument
as you might imagine.
And I do wanna be clear, Iím not saying that
this border wasnít incredibly dangerous and
plenty of the locals, even if they did know
the terrain would lose their lives and limbs
in attempt to cross it.
The border was absolutely horrific and I do
not mean to diminish that.
If you were an outsider that didnít know
how the system worked you would likely be
killed trying to cross it.
Iím just trying to spotlight these exceptions
to the rule to show what was actually possible
within the system.
Given our overwhelming emphasis on the borders
horrors I think itís important to show this
other side of the coin.
So here, again, is a sketch by one young man
who befriended a border soldier at a bar,
he devised this elaborate plan to cross the
border and he did cross the border, 3 times
within a couple years in the 1980s.
And these kinds of documents are in peopleís
homes, they come out when you talk with them
and I canít give you any precise number for
them.
I really canít, I wish I could, so much of
this is anecdotal but their sheer existence,
I believe, really shifts our understanding
of the border and I look forward to future
research revealing just what was happening
here.
But the point is that East Germanyís physical
fortifications were far more fallible than
we tend to think.
In the 60s, especially, youíd get rotten
mine fields, the border was riddled with rust
and breakable barbed wire.
This two and half year old toddled across
the border unscathed, losing a shoe, crossing
a mine field, crossing a mind field in four
layers of barbed wire.
His mother told me he simply wandered off
from a festival, wound up in the West, was
asleep when a couple found him.
So these, apparently he was too light to set
off the mines and thatís why this was possible
but still, this gives you a sense of what
was actually happening on the ground.
[Coughing]
>>Edith Sheffer: Even in the 70s and 80s the
border was plagued by malfunctions, defunct
trip wires, signal fences, heavy snowfall
could trigger a bunch of land mines going
off, they were decoy cut outs of boulder,
border soldiers put in watch towers to give
the impression there were more soldiers on
the border than there were.
And locals would still cross impulsively.
These were mostly young men and teenagers,
just because, and theyíd be fighting with
parents, theyíd be fighting with a girlfriend,
theyíd get poor grades in school or they
were simply bored with life in a provincial
back water.
In the 1960s, officials estimated that 90
percent of these local crossers were male,
over three quarters were under the age of
25, a third were in trouble with the law and
half were just plain drunk.
[Laughter]
>>Edith Sheffer: Crossing on a dare or something
like that.
And there was a kind of border subculture
in the 1960s, especially, where the frontier
was kind of an adventure playground, teenagers
would improvise frontier hideaways and tree
look outs, dare each other to cross, sneaking
west for day trips.
But these crossings, again, did not make it
into official statistics.
Iíve found a lot of these cases in the basement
of the Neustadt police archives, completely
neglected and who knows, perhaps slated for
destruction.
So Iíd like to suggest that while daring
escape stories of tunnels and homemade air
balloons dominated Western headlines, at least
as many crossings were not the considered
the attempts of people to try and flee tyranny
but the random exploits of local residents.
So, in sum, I believe that this potential
for subversion suggests that the strength
of the iron curtain depended less upon its
physical defenses than, again, upon the accommodation
of border residents and this anticipatory
compliance.
So the ultimate fall of the Berlin Wall in
1989, I think, tells us something about what
helped sustain the iron curtain.
People had cumulatively feared and adjusted
to the iron curtain but when Gorbachev, Perestroika
and confusions in the East German leadership
made another reality seem possible on November
9th, 1989.
The threshold of fear finally tipped and the
iron curtain unexpectedly collapsed.
People walked to the Berlin Wall en masse
and assembled at check points, one of them
was here at the Behrenstrasse.
This is where the Berlin Wall first opened,
there was a crowd, there was an angry crowd
and border officials did not know what to
do and improvised and opened the Berlin Wall.
Thatís how the Berlin Wall fell.
There was a crowd that demanded it to be open.
And this, to me, suggests that the strength
of the iron curtain resided also within citizens
not just the concrete barriers.
So, to conclude, Iíve just given you a slice
of this research but I hope youíve gotten
a sense for just how multilayered the iron
curtain actually was.
This was no neat, tidy story of a monolithic
barrier, the story that we usually associate
with the Berlin Wall.
Rather, when you look at the full history
of the iron curtain, you see this jumble of
events.
And although the vast majority of people did
not want this barrier, and this is the poignancy,
they wound up sustaining it through everyday
accommodations.
So I see three broader implications of this
story.
First it illustrates how geopolitical phenomena
are not just shaped by ideologies and state
powers but also by the people who live them.
I donít mean to deny the centrality of high
politics but this shows the intersection of
private choices and public events.
And Iím arguing for the geopolitical significance
of these small actions by everyday choices
of ordinary people.
Second, Germany in the Cold War looked different
from this iron curtain.
Thereís the sense that Germany normalized
quickly after the third Reich.
West Germany became this model of Western
markets and democracy and the Berlin Wall
was a geopolitical tragedy that did not reflect
German society.
Iím not contending there is anything uniquely
German about the iron curtain, Iíd like to
be clear on this, but I do want to point out
that it did arise from a specific historical
context.
After 12 years of Nazism in the third Reich,
6 years of war and foreign invasion, nervous
Germans came to enforce and accept border
against other Germans.
The barrier emerged from the Nazi past and
it remained tied to that past, it was called
the concentration camp wall in the West, it
was called an anti fascist defensive barrier
in the East.
And Germanyís post war development looks
a lot less peaceable from this iron curtain.
Here was a belt of violence at the center
of Europe, a fault line between Communism
and capitalism, it was not at war but it was
also not at peace.
So, again, here you see the creating of difference
where there was no difference.
The institutionalization of violence among
neighbors and popular participation in a system
that was deeply unpopular, and, most shocking
to me, normalizing a monstrosity that is growing
in your midst.
And lastly, I think the story spotlights the
fragility of a society in crisis.
Enmeshed in a confusing chain of events where
outcomes are unclear and what the possibilities
of this are.
So the wall is not just a symbol of political
failure but also of social breakdown.
And although Germans may wanna believe their
partition was made of iron, it was made of
something all too human; behavior and belief.
This is why it was so quick to go up and so
quick to go down.
And since the iron curtain is so often invoked
in debates about todayís walls such as in
the U.S. with Mexico and in the Middle East,
we should learn the lessons of its fortification.
Fortification was a short term response to
structural conflict that failed to solve underlying
problems and, as we see, created different
problems of its own.
It entrenched new forms of violence and magnified
divisions and it penetrated its society deeply.
Micro steps can, indeed, have far reaching
results.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>>Presenter: So, if you have any questions
come on over to the mic cause weíre recording
this.
>>female #1: So, I have a question about the
first phase in 1949 through 52.
Did you get any sense from your interviews
or from your research about that fact that
people stayed because it was their home?
I mean, my house is here, my business is here,
my people are here, my familyís here, why
would I move?
Why would I go away?
Sort of motivating them to stay and not understanding
downstream the consequences of anything that
might happen out of that, can you say a little
bit more about that?
>>Edith Sheffer: Yeah, absolutely.
And this, I think, speaks to the exact point;
nobody knew what was gonna happen.
And, so, when you talk, I assume youíre talking
about East Germans who stayed in Sonneberg
and didnít go to the West.
Yeah, they would have a business, they would
have parents they were taking care of, they
would have a whole life, a whole community
where they were living and it wasnít clear
what was gonna happen.
Many thought that this barrier was ridiculous
and it would be temporary and no one could
imagine it could actually be permanent.
Then, ironically, as the border became stronger
and stronger it got harder to leave because
it implicated your relatives if you left.
They would pay the consequences in not being
able to attend universities or follow the
career of their choice.
So there were a lot of reasons that people
wound up staying and it was absolutely a very
complicated calculation.
And, as you said, in this early period it
was hard to know what was gonna happen.
>>male #1: I have a, first question, did the
formation of the wall and separation of the
society change East Germany and West Germany
in ways other than the political system?
I had a German professor who said the language
was changing and what happened culturally
between the two halves because of the separation?
>>Edith Sheffer: Yeah and exactly as you say
itís amazing to me two different cultures
formed out of one formerly similar region.
And this happened in a variety of ways.
Germans talk about this famous wall in the
head, you may have heard about this, and people
say it still exists between East and West
Germans, thereís this wall in the head which
is not only a cultural divide but a mental
divide.
Some people believe East and West Germans
walk differently, talk differently, have different
postures, eat different foods, think differently,
behave at work differently and these differences
persist twenty years after the wall.
How are they created?
Even something as simple as different brands
that you get in the supermarket create a sense
of identity and so some East German brands
that went out of business after the fall of
the wall have been reintroduced because there
was this "ostalgie" means East, nostalgia
for these old brands and people felt this
loss of home because, you know, theyíve been
so enmeshed in this completely different culture.
So, yeah.
>>male #1: I have one more comment.
I happened to have seen three of these walls
in 1973
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: Great.
>>male #1: I crossed the wall from Hamburg
to Berlin and then we came back on the Autobahn.
I was at the Brandenburg Gate and I swear
to God that we walked up on a sunny day and
instantly dust and the winds and the clouds
came over and I felt more scared than Iíve
ever felt before.
Walking around the campground we didnít have
any money we were camping, we came to this
sign in Russian, French and English saying
youíre now leaving the American zone.
And I went, well I wonít say exactly what
I said, but
[Laughter]
>>male #1: Oh my God, then I crossed the border
into Mexico to build houses to Tijuana and
had very much the same feeling, standing on
both sides of that wall seeing what was written
on one side versus nothing on the American
side except, well the, and then this year
Iíve been to Palestine crossing from Jerusalem
to Bethlehem and seeing that, my question
is how do societies cope with separations
like this where people cannot meet each other
day to day basis and is it worse than things
like apartheid or the discrimination system
in the United States where people were separated
by culture but met on a day to day basis?
>>Edith Sheffer: wow.
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: Yeah, youíve just made a
lot of really interesting linkages between
different phenomenonís.
Iím not sure I can synthesize everything
that youíre saying but youíre stimulating
a lot of interesting ideas.
I think one thing that happened with division
in Germany that maybe isnít happening when
you have systems of apartheid or discrimination
is that you can romanticize the other size
and ascribe greater similarities or connections
than might actually exist.
So I think, unlike situations of difference
where youíre constantly bumping into the
other when you have an other thatís distant,
itís possible to imagine these connections
and then in the case of Germany what happened
is that you have this romance that I think
gets wildly disappointed when the two sides
are united again.
And, so, yeah Iím not sure to what extent
this might hold for others cases of partition
but, you know, I think as we think about what
might happen in Korea, you know, people are
already saying we should be cognizant of the
German example and what might happen, it might
not all be as rosy as we might expect.
These walls in the head may very well still
exist.
So, I think itís trickier when you get to
situations like the U.S. Mexican border and
this security fence in the Middle East because
is there, was that a cohesive community to
begin with?
Yeah, so, yeah but thank you.
>>female #2: Yeah, actually that goes really
well with the question I was gonna ask about
how this internalized duality seemed to define
citizenship as it was, or as it was experienced
by East and West Germans and I was gonna ask
the rate at which you saw that or which Germans
saw that decline following the collapse of
the walls, which I guess you kind of spoke
to in your answer to the last question but
my follow up question would be to what extent,
this is a generational experience weíre in,
folks born in the early 80s or late 80s or
even 90s have no idea what some of these older
folks or members of their family are talking
about when they speak of these things.
Like, walls in the head.
>>Edith Sheffer: Yeah.
No, thatís a great question, too.
So, I mean, if I get what youíre asking what
are the variables that are determining to
what extent people still feel this disconnection
and a lot does have to do with generation
but not all.
I think a lot depends on where you live, what
your socioeconomic status is, to what extent
do you have your self opportunities and if
you donít, what extent might you blame that
[Laughs]
>>Edith Sheffer: On the cause of people living
on the other side.
So, whereas, if youíre young and in Berlin
you might have a very different outlook.
If you live in border region I studied, tensions
are rampant if anything, things are more tense
than they were before the wall fell down.
And, in fact, these identities have been inherited.
So there was a poll a few years ago of teenagers
who had no living experience with the iron
curtain, they were all born after 1989 and
only 35 percent said they would readily date
someone who lived in the opposite town.
So, and then when you poll their parents which
is what I did, you get these amazing biases
about would you be okay with your child marrying
the child of someone born on the other side?
And I think only 56 percent of Westerners
said they would be okay with that and if you
can imagine an American being so open about
expressing that degree of prejudice thatís
rather interesting.
So I think the answer is in some pockets of
Germany, maybe in sort of a more depressed
region like I studied thatís right on top
of these frictions, you get these inherited
animosities but I think the real positive
thing is in the younger generation and these
major urban centers the story looks very different.
[Pause]
>>Presenter: Okay, Thank you.
[Applause]